anyway ladies and gentlemen thank God
there's no game tonight because
otherwise one of our performers wouldn't
be able to be here tonight here were two
artists who have three Academy Awards 20
nominations between them and then here
in person ladies and gentlemen the Joker
and Dick Tracy mr. Jack Nicholson mr.
Warren Beatty
[Applause]
[Music]
the nominees for Best Picture are born
on the 4th of July a kit Minho and
Oliver Stone producers Dead Poets
Society Stephen haft Paul younger
whipped and Tony Thomas producers
Driving Miss Daisy
Richard days anak and Lili fini zanuck
producers Field of Dreams Lawrence
Gordon and Charles Gordon producers my
left foot Knoll Pierson producer and the
Oscar goes to
Driving Miss Daisy
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Thank You Academy we're up here for
really one very simple reason and that's
the fact that Bruce Beresford is a
brilliant director it's as simple as
that
our everlasting thanks to gruesome to
alfred yuri whose words of love and
wisdom touched us all our thanks to a
great cast Jessica and Morgan Danny and
the rest are thanks to a wonderful crew
those in Atlanta as well as those here
and we thank David Brown for being very
instrumental in the early stages of this
production and to our partner and dear
friend who had such great faith in us
from the very beginning and in this
project from the very beginning Jerry
grant gl I'd very much like to thank the
people at Warner Brothers Alan Stewart
and and Jakob roots for taking care of
us and Bob Daley Terry Semel Ravi
Friedman Joel Wayne Rob Friedman I said
that twice died McIlwain Ronnie Jason
and very much the group in London and
majestic and I would like to thank
Ronnie Jason and I hope I'm as religious
all the rest of the years I've been the
last two months and I and I would very
much like to thank the Academy for
honoring us and making my mama so proud
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Applause]